this is a Wendover productions video
made possible by back plays and in
collaboration with alternate history hub
and real life lore russia is immense
it spans 5000 miles across two thousand
miles vertically crosses 11 time zones
borders everywhere from Norway to North
Korea and it is close to Anchorage as it
is to Amsterdam it's huge but it has a
problem a problem that can explain part
of why the average Russian living at the
same latitude as Finland Sweden Norway
Iceland and Canada makes only 7500
American dollars per year a problem that
can explain at least a portion of almost
every political decision the country has
ever made russia's geography is flawed
well you have to remember about Russia
is the majority of Russians live in
Europe three-quarters of Russia's
population lives in the Western quarter
of the country therefore as a country
with a fairly centralized power system
many of its decisions go to protect the
country core in and around Moscow you
see a lot of the success of certain
countries over others depends on how
well is geography protected the US for
example benefited hugely from being an
ocean away from every large military
power
the only real armed forces that could
threaten the u.s. in its infancy were in
Europe or Asia and therefore any
invasion would require transoceanic
supply lines which are hugely expensive
and logistically difficult therefore
weakening an invading army on the
European continent France has a similar
situation their northwestern border is
protected by the English Channel their
western border by the Atlantic Ocean
their southern border by the Pyrenees
Mountains and the Mediterranean ocean
their southeastern by the owl's
mountains and their northeastern by the
Rhine River the eastern half of their
northern border is however largely
unprotected geographically a flawed
Germany exploited in both World War 1
and World War two by invading through
Belgium and Luxembourg but the
protection still did concentrate attacks
into a choke point and kept it
significantly more protected than other
European countries here's Cody from
alternate history hug to explain
Russia's territorial expansion Russia's
first territorial expansion was entirely
a quest for power starting when it
unified into a single East Slavic state
in 882 but over time this expanse for
glory transformed into an effort to
protect the core of the country this
early Russia was very unprotected and
vulnerable
there was no geographic protection to
keep foreigners from migrating into
Russian lands the only natural resource
the fledgling nation had at their
disposal was pure van power in the
coming centuries what was then known as
the Grand Duchy of Moscow quickly
expanded by the time Ivan the Terrible
was crowned ruler of the Czar 'dom of
Russia the country had spread its
borders east to the Urals south to the
Caucasus and west to the Carpathian
Mountains eventually even Siberia was
conquered which before then was an
independent Conny
a territory ruled by a Khan that was
Cody from alternate history hub I
collaborated with him to make a great
video on his channel about what the
world would be like if Russia had never
become its own country which I'll link
in the description and at the end of the
video now with all this territory Russia
or at least Moscow had some serious
protection Siberia is large enough that
no army could invade through it and make
it to Moscow the supply lines would have
to be thousands of miles along through
inhospitable conditions not only that
but the army with a one or two thousand
mile long supply line would then have to
make it over the Ural Mountains to get
to Moscow attacking from the south or
west would also take an army either
across water or through mountains by the
time a 19th century rolled in Russia had
truly become an unconquered below
countries could and can take over
portions of Russia but there is no
conceivable way that a single country
could fully occupy and conquer Russia to
occupy a territory of that size a
country would need an estimated 13
million trained ground troops more than
the 17 largest militaries combined
however despite its defenses Russia has
never developed economically to the same
level as some of its neighbors its GDP
per capita is right around that of
Mauritius Grenada and Turkey and this
once again can be at least partially
attributed to geography historically
naval power equalled
our the two were synonymous there was no
better way for countries to project
their power and grow their economy than
to have a powerful Navy and merchant
fleet many of the most powerful
countries today the United Kingdom Japan
and China for example were ones that
once had the most powerful navies in the
world there's a reason that none of the
18 largest economies in the world are
landlocked countries up until the last
century maritime shipping was the
fastest way to get goods and people
across the world and it's still the
cheapest way to ship goods long distance
having good water access allows
countries to trade with the world but
Russia despite its 23,000 miles of
coastline has no significant warm water
ice free ports with direct access to an
ocean Alaska does Canada does Iceland
does Norway does and Sweden too but
Russia is fundamentally limited in its
maritime power because it has no easy
way to access the world's oceans
year-round the port of novorossiya is
ice-free but it's stupid is limited by
the depth and size of the port st.
Petersburg also has an important port
but it freezes for many months of the
year on the Pacific side ports like
Vladivostok also occasionally freeze
during the winter but the ice is not the
biggest problem with these ports the
biggest problem is that their access to
the world's oceans is all through choke
points controlled by either NATO
countries or NATO allies to get to the
ocean from Novara Sisk you need to pass
through the Bosphorus Strait which is
controlled by turkey a NATO country to
get to the ocean from st. Petersburg you
need to pass through the Danish straits
controlled by Denmark also a NATO
country and to get to the ocean from
Vladivostok and many of the other
Pacific ports you need to pass through
the Sea of Japan which is controlled by
Japan a close ally of NATO if Russia
ever decided to attack a NATO country or
Ally their access to the world's oceans
would be restricted by these NATO
countries because the NATO treaty
includes of a mutual defense pact if one
country is attacked all respond this
would both Russia's Navy and
economy now back to the fences there's
one major flaw to Russia's geographical
defence system the northern European
plain whereas every other border has a
geographical
preventing easy invasion from a foreign
army this completely flat plane just
acts as a funnel easily bringing an army
from Western Europe right up to Moscow
well a large part of the Soviet Union's
motive to expand into Eastern Europe was
to spread the socialist revolution
Stalin still believed that he needed to
create a zone of buffer states in order
to defend against the threat of the USA
and its allies in Western Europe with
its influence over all of Eastern Europe
the USSR had both manpower and political
power to keep the West far from Moscow
since the fall of the Soviet Union
Russia has continued to strive to keep
political power in the region out of the
15 states have emerged 12 join the
Commonwealth of Independent States with
Russia essentially aligning them
politically with Russia while three join
both NATO and the European Union
Lithuania Latvia and Estonia that means
that on paper Russia still has a strong
political buffer between it and Western
Europe the Russian exclave of
Kaliningrad and the countries of Belarus
and Ukraine covered almost all of the
northern European plain not only that
but Russia used its influence in Ukraine
to sign a long-term lease on the warm
water port of Sevastopol which greatly
expanded the naval capabilities of
Russia's Black Sea Fleet except Ukraine
as a whole progress to be more and more
pro-european in the decades following
the fall of the Soviet Union which was a
major reason for Russia's invasion of
Crimea while on the surface Putin might
have claimed Russia's invasion was to
save the Russians of the area from the
increasingly westernizing country the
annexation of Crimea was in reality a
strategic imperative to keep the warm
water port of Sevastopol a Ukraine that
was friendlier to the West likely would
have ended Russia's lease on the port so
in Putin's mind he needed to invade
Crimea in order to prevent a crippling
blow to Russia's ocean access now Russia
has managed to overcome many of its
Geographic challenges partially because
of two things oil and natural gas it has
enormous energy reserves partially
because of its enormous size Russian
natural gas pipelines provide for 40
percent of Europe's natural gas demand
some countries such as Bulgaria
let the wing
Latvia Estonia and Finland are almost
fully dependent on Russia for their
natural gas this gas dependency is a
major reason why Germany for example a
country with high Russian oil dependency
is much less likely to criticize Russia
than a country like the UK which has
virtually zero Russian gas dependency if
Russia shut off the gas to Germany it
would devastate them but stopping gas
exports to the UK would have little
effect
the US has attempted to reduce Russian
influence in Europe by exporting
liquefied natural gas across the
Atlantic it costs more but it allows
Western European countries to buy their
energy from their American allies now
none of this discussion of ports and
power is to say that if there was no
Norway or Sweden blocking the way to the
ocean and the water was a bit warmer
Russia would be the Sweden of the East
saying that would be foolish
geography does have an enormous
influence on human development but it
doesn't determine it much of history is
defined by chance not circumstance
because in the end reality is just a
confluence of chance and circumstance
this video was made possible by pact
please so I was going to do this big
complicated pitch where I figured out
the value of computer data in order to
calculate the return on investment for
signing up to Backblaze but then it was
pointed out to me that you already know
that you should back up your data it's
like brushing your teeth doing the
dishes taking out the trash is something
that you know you should do but don't
want to because it's easy to ignore it
the only thing is backing up your data
doesn't have to be difficult or
expensive with Backblaze you just
download their application to your
computer pay $5 per month and it works
in the background continuously backing
up your data you can just completely
forget about it if you ever do lose your
data all you have to do is sign into
your account at back please calm and
download your data if your internet
isn't fast enough they even have an
option to ship you a physical drive with
your data instead what's best is that
you can try this out for free for 15
days by using the link back please calm
slash Wendover if you lose your data
during those 15 days you'll still get it
back at no cost
after that it's only five dollars per
month for the peace of mind of knowing
that no matter what your data is safe by
signing up at this link you'll also
be helping me out so I can make more
great Wendover productions videos once
again sign up over at Backblaze comm
slash Wendover to get a 15 day free
trial that's 15 days of knowing your
data is safe I want to remind you to
check out the video that alternate
history hub made about what the world
would be like if Russia didn't exist
it's a great video and then he
collaborated with real-life floor to
make another great video about what
would happen if the Soviet Union
reunited other than that you can support
Wendover productions at patreon.com
slash window reproductions follow me on
twitter at 1-over Pro check out my fan
motor a subreddit here and most of all
subscribe to this channel to receive all
my future videos right when they come
out thanks again for watching and I'll
see you in two weeks for another
Wendover productions video